if
you know 10 years ago we would speak
about exchanges you would again think on
a nation national grade exchange but
today you and i can open an exchange and
launch into one launch of tomorrow
morning and it's not necessarily a
crypto exchange it could be a new
futures derivatives equities something
with a different topology and every
financial instrument has a different
topology hence also the fact that the
infrastructure is so outdated today that
it cannot sustain those new instruments
that are being introduced
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
meet guy milamed a co-founder and ceo of
xberry the exchange technology pioneer
that is revolutionizing the traditional
capital markets and digital assets
guy is also a venture partner and the
only blockchain hedge fund in israel
finova capital and he is experienced in
developing go-to-market strategies
product market fit and business
strategies
guys a seasoned expert blend of
entrepreneurial pedigree with corporate
strength he launched xberry to reshape
opportunities for all market models from
the biggest exchange in the world to
startups and anything in between
guy milamed welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so excited to have you here with me
how are you
um great michael thank you for having me
i'm pretty excited as well
20 minutes to spend on another topic
that i know very little about talking to
somebody who knows a lot about it
uh what a gift that i have and and and
today
talking about exchanges and marketplaces
and your own
journey um
guy get me started a little bit about
you know yourself and sort of
just a little bit about your journey and
how you ended up in exchanges and
marketplaces as a field
so it's it's so it's a long slap it's
been it's been a it's really a long trip
i've been 20 years in the tech industry
started my career originally as a
product and product strategist worked in
education technology mass consumer
products natural language understanding
various technologies shared mobility and
in the last 12 something years i've been
in the fintech sector and since
2016 deep interest also in crypto and
blockchain
um always looking for the right use
cases and the right implementations of
technology that could really uh you know
revolutionize or revolutionize certain
industries
um and i've had the chance to encounter
my uh
let's say partners in axiory
and uh when they shared the initial
thoughts and and
and the demo that uh they've built um on
a certain let's say hypothesis
i started diving deeper and deeper i
didn't know anything about capital
markets i knew what everyone knows on
the street but um
but suddenly when i started analyzing
the market and analyzing the tech that
exists there you know i was attracted
into this world
um
and actually i found everything that as
an entrepreneur and i've been a serial
entrepreneur all my career
these are the right elements that
connect me to a certain
to find the right solution for for a
certain industry and certain problem
um so once i got in it just sucked me in
it was like the perfect timing present
the perfect solution with the perfect
technology uh to an industry that
you know once every 25 years is going
through an evolution and we're simply
living at that time right now
incredible and and tell me a little bit
about this industry and and about this
cyclical nature of these revolutions
you're talking about
so
as we look at the world of exchanges and
marketplaces and i think you know when
we when we speak of exchanges everyone
knows the national stock exchange
but the world has been changing
drastically it's been growing
exponentially and and changing in in its
the infrastructure
is the in its majority ruled by the big
birds by the nasdaq of the world and and
millenniums of the world the euro next
and the cmes of the world
um but the infrastructure
haven't changed for the last 25 to 40
years you know because i've been using
mainframes uh and this kind of solution
so one momentum was the infrastructure
is totally outdated
um the other momentum is that everything
happens
on-prem and the dream of moving to the
cloud has been there on the table for a
while now but
the way of solving it is pretty complex
for many reasons regulatory performance
scale robustness and i think another
interesting momentum and that's the
momentum of the market the market is
being diversified in its many
instruments financial instruments that
are being introduced once we used to
have only stocks option uh commodities
equities today we have futures we have
nfts we have cryptos we have assets new
assets that are being created today
today in extraordinary we see everyday
assets that surprise us by the
creativity of the new entrepreneurs and
the new markets i think last but not
least
if
you know 10 years ago we would speak
about exchanges you would again think on
a national national grade exchange but
today you and i can open an exchange and
launch into one launcher tomorrow
morning and it's not necessarily a
crypto exchange it could be a new
futures uh derivatives equities
something with a different apology and
every financial instrument has a
different topology hands-on so the fact
that the infrastructure is so outdated
today that it cannot sustain those new
instruments that are being introduced
um into the market i think another thing
that was very interesting in the world
of problem and we speak for a second
we're trying to sketch the world and the
world of problem that we're touching
here
um
is the fact uh not only by the fact that
we're moving into the cloud
but um that we need to
build something which is asked agnostic
okay we need to be able to take every
instrument and be able to launch it this
market has been very slow up today in
order for us to launch an exchange it'll
take you three to four years put aside
all the regulatory and financial issues
wow okay so
you know in in the way we live today uh
you know when we speak about email
systems or things that have been
revolutionized in the last you know 20
years
um
it's it's unacceptable for us as
entrepreneurs or businessmen that'll
take us four years to touch the market
um so there are many challenges serious
challenges
and on the other hand uh there is a
serious opportunity as well because the
market is looking for this for that
change you need also a vast amount of
capital to launch an exchange which is
also you know if only you and i are
opening an exchange
we cannot expect everyone to have four
to 15 million dollars to launch exchange
and pay for tech again on-prem cost of
ownership with it which is very heavy
um and buy your own servers and manage
your own service so there has been some
small successes in launching parts of it
to the cloud
but it hasn't happened yet in the way
expert perceives the market and it's not
only the market in in on the capital
markets but it's almost going to macro
and looking at the economy what's going
through right now
no no that it's fantastic but taking one
step back to to this idea of exchange
and and what motivates
new organizations or new
personnel to create new exchanges
well what does that effectively mean for
both the people that are building the
exchange and how does it impact at the
end those that are taking part in this
new marketplace
yeah so i think first of all like every
other business um let's let's speak for
a second about the existing exchanges
they want to digitize the assets okay so
have a faster ramp up introduce new
assets today when you're introducing new
assets it's not being supported you'll
need to wait another year a year and a
half before you get the right release of
the software and again we're going back
in time in the way we speak about it
okay this is another way we're a
full-size company we push everything as
us
um
so software as a service um
the second thing is is it's time to
market i don't have four years to spend
now only on launching a market
um
the third point is the cost of ownership
okay why do we need to spend millions of
dollars to hold servers on-prem and 50
developers that will accept that when
you serve me at last
um so these things
first of all will help you switch and
revolutionize from your existing legacy
or proprietary technology it doesn't
matter one of the bold
okay and the second one for new
exchanges
they already start
creating much more sophisticated markets
sophisticated markets could be connected
to the full supply chain okay so if you
invest in gold so you'll be connected
with supply chain collateralized on a
real gold and you'll be connected to the
real warehouse which controls the gold
and you'll have michael's name on it and
you know when you put take a position on
a goal it's a collateralized assets and
you see more and more sophisticated
assets like these today
and really creative entrepreneurs that
are either starting new markets or wanna
evolutionize their own existing
traditional markets
and
you need new infrastructure to do that
if you stick with your own one your
margins will kill you your high cost and
until you touch the market you'll be
outdated again
um so these are only small the you know
the major the major uh things that will
motivate you either to switch tech
and you know i'm not here to say to an
existing market which is running a
billion dollar base switcher all day the
tech in one day you know we've been
we've been in business for a while now
um
but there are ways of doing that so we
will take your most innovative assets
that cannot be implemented in your old
school tech and you will start it and
you rather juxtaposed to your existing
traditional ultrawide again you can see
suddenly that you run faster
you get all your features in a matter of
weeks days okay you launch your market
within days
um
and you're being able to scale up and
scale down and not pay millions of
dollars for a farm or of hardware
uh so if we have only 100 trades today
because we only started the market
united
so we'll pay for the 100 trades you
won't pay for 100 million trades
i think last but not least is the
technological um
gap of being able to run high frequency
low latency trading in the cloud
and today experience the only one that
is capable of running a million and a
half transactions per second in
microseconds latency and wow being able
to do that and improves the time
and the cost
by more than 50 compared with your
compared with existing leading on-prem
solutions and that is and and that is a
great achievement uh uh for us for ample
and we see again
we see what's happening out there and
the big birds has been doing an amazing
job for for the last years but they take
some time to know um a fresh start to to
be able to to build maybe something else
incredible so so really
spell it out for me you know how does
xberry play into this play into this
ecosystem how does it play into these
you know these existing exchanges and
marketplaces by reinventing the
technology or by cr or creating new
exchanges um i i'm completely blown away
by by the numbers you're telling me
about it then about about the
the ability to make further transactions
per second but
what is actually experience role within
our ecosystem today
i think that's a great question so we
started everything by
understanding where the heart of the
market is and the heart of the market
is in price discovery so the matching
trading tech is one of the most uh
complicated place
uh that could take place on cloud
so we started from the uh from that
component component these engines are
highly complex
uh and highly advanced
and what we did we built an engine which
is first of all asked agnostic
it's cloud native it was born in cloud
it's not born on an on-prem architecture
that has been exported to the cloud and
still have a problem with cost hence you
have a problem with robustness and scale
this one was born again with the most
advanced tax tech that one can find
today
um
so we're asked agnostic um
if you're a small exchange you can run
on multi-tenant and you'll pay only a
small portion of the space that you're
using and if you grow to become a
monster doing a million transactions per
second but you don't have that many
markets today i have to say
um
then then you you will scale up with you
um we're blockchain agnostic and that's
very interesting that's where the future
markets are entering why because today
the settlement
uh process in regulated markets uh is
running on the t plus two on the this
place seven
it takes time before actually the the
process of an acquisition is being done
um
and today we have instruments financial
instruments that as you know are highly
liquid
and you would like to have a real time
or a near real-time settlement process
the only way i'm doing that today
is using blockchain and there's nothing
that i like more at last is to use
blockchain for real use cases and we see
that happening more and more today
and hence also when you connect to
markets that are tokenizing if you want
to start tokenizing certain assets then
naturally you will need to have also
blockchain in one of the layers of the
infrastructure but again i always say
when i meet people from the industry
also from crypto industry again we serve
well i'll give you in a second an
overview of some of the clients that we
serve and you'll understand why the
range is so wide and that's why we
decided to create something which is an
asset agnostic and can actually touch
all the markets which created expiry to
touch the most
extreme highly regulated national stock
exchanges through digital securities
crypto nfcs whatever you decide and
unregulated markets sports um esports
gaming uh fish market wine market art
market whatever you want to tokenize
whatever you want to start trading using
a central order
and why is that we believe in x-ray that
the only way you're running a market
and
when i say we were born in a high in the
enterprise regulated world
we thought that that would be the right
package for what expertise brings to the
market
we believe that regulators eventually
will work only with centralized
i love b5 and they're an amazing b5
solution out there but the regulator
will have serious issues with working on
big fights uh with big files um in in
regulated
locations definitely tier one steer
tools
um
so
going back to direct your question the
first part was the matching trading tech
um and once we had that we created
something which was highly robust and
scalable
uh with all the features that i
mentioned and many more
again you get everything in the service
you don't worry about your tech you
don't need people to accept to develop
upon it you need a feature you get it
pushed to you and you and you manage it
you upload the market and believe me
mikhail within five minutes you and i
can upload the market show tomorrow to
all our shareholders and within
five days maximum two months you could
be up and running production
including a ui and that's when we came
with nebula nebula is our next
generation offering that went out to the
market
a couple of months ago and nebula is the
first end-to-end solution
so we've developed extra components from
tokenizing an asset
running the ledgers the operating
management system
the trading and the matching all the way
through white label ui so basically
we took out the state of the loan
industry and we said listen if you want
to build your own market and you want to
you know mikhail will take care of your
regulation guy will do business or vice
versa
that's it don't worry about your tech
don't worry about your i.t okay you'll
have your market operation naturally
things that that bother you
and and that was a very big notion to
the industry
this specific product product was a
solution was
meant especially for ditch securities
and digital assets so digitized assets
is regulators and unregulated
so so what what are some
examples of players today that are that
are using experience
so um so first of all highly regulated
markets uh so commodities futures
equities um one of the world
unfortunately
if you compare it to other ventures that
i've managed in the past and you know
one of the things you know
that i've always used to say you know
focus on one location let's let's see
that we have a product market fit the
product market sheet we had was idiot it
was the fastest one that i had in my
career within three months we closed the
phase of the product market tree
uh wow and um
so our our our location of our clients
is an apac is in the gold um is in um us
naturally uh europe and central america
um and we've got so i said regulated
markets uh we've got several pocs
running already with with with the
leading national stock exchanges around
the world which is which is nice but the
future markets that we serve today
are are crazy and pretty exciting i have
to say because there you see the real
assets so uh there there is a new
there's a new futures market on music
which is going to come out soon which is
pretty exciting um
[Music]
approved by an american regulator um and
there's an influencer index that is also
going to come out in the us in the
coming two months which is very exciting
we've got an esports marketplace uh
which drives us all crazy so we're gonna
start a competition soon with the most
attractive assets being traded by
experience um so we see them all and the
fact that there are acid agnostic again
that that's the place where we see also
most of our competitors
um fall off the table because they
cannot take this kind of topology i
couldn't care less what we trade if we
decide to trade now you know whatever we
do and and that's the thing the price
discovery uh because you said in the
beginning i'm have very happy on that
michel you've mentioned marketplaces
and the way we see marketplaces and and
when i look at gmc at gen z's today okay
they want fairness
the thing about exchanges that we love
most that it's fair you know if you're
entering a stock exchange right now with
the nice elastic oh whomever okay and
you buy a stock or an option
you don't worry about your money you
worry about whether you took the right
decision or not that's something else
especially states
but you know you see the price discovery
so you see the history of the certain
stock and the price and the supply and
the demand imagine you do all your
shopping like that imagine when you go
into a
an online shop you'll see the full
history you'll be able to make a smart
decision when you buy when you shop
things and these are also some of the
clients that we see today selling
minerals or or
rare wines
um
and and
and it's uh it's amazing it's amazing
way to to do your uh your business
well
it's a guy i think naturally i didn't
mention
go ahead no no go ahead sorry
yeah i forgot the crypto exchanges that
we run as well a month and a half ago we
just won the the number one uh engine
for crypto exchanges as well
uh
nfts naturally uh also uh a lot of a lot
of a lot of buzz but you know we're
trying we're trying to keep it real um
hence also the reason that we work with
regulators and we go hand in hand with
our clients through regulators
i have a guy i feel like i got a boot
camp of information that i can now take
with me and and go and explore this new
world that i that i already
know then the other way around i'm
thanking you because this was this is
exactly why i i started this show and
and and i really love it and i'm
it's amazing to me
how technology
is used in in such a such a variety of
ways and it to to change the way that we
interact with our world around us and so
i i really appreciate you coming here
and sharing with me your journey and in
general as an entrepreneur but also
specifically with xberry and uh and i
wish you best of luck on this journey
and i can't wait to dive deeper invite
you for another episode in the future to
talk about what's happening and uh stay
safe and still healthy in the meantime
thank you midfield for inviting me it's
been a pleasure and it's great to meet
you and i hope i'll talk to you soon
thanks for your time
i appreciate it very much thank you guy
thank you
you